LINEUP.
TAVARES.
HERE'S KERFOOT, HE
KERFOOT OUT HIGH IN THE SLOT,
ABLE TO TAKE THAT SHOT, RIGHT UP
OVER TO CENTER BY FLEURY.
COUNTERATTACK FOR DONSKOI IN THE
OFF WING, WRAPPED U
FLEURY, GETS IT ON AND OFF THE
STICK, CAMPBELL IS ABLE TO
SQUEEZE AND HOLD O TERRITORY.
HOP
APPLETON FINDS JARNKROK OFF THE
SLOT.
RIGHT
LAUZON.
BUNTING, HE SCORES.
ON A RICOCHET. FRONT.
SOMETIMES GOING BACK IN YOUR
ZONE WING.
GET OUT THROUGH. GIORDANO.
REILLY, THEY JUST GET PUCKS TO
THE NET AND TWICE.
SPEZZA SLAPPED PAST, TIP, THEY
SENDS IT BACK.
THIS IS
IF THAT PUCK'S NOT WOBBLING, MO
CENTER ICE, MOVES IT BACK, DON'
LOOK TO SETTLE UP.
GOPE IT IN.
MITCH MARN PASS,
THE STICK IT BACK FOR JARNKROK.
MOVING ACROSS NOW, HITS RIGHT O
GLOVE OF CAMPBELL, ABLE TO FIND.
PEPPERED BY SANDIN.
SEVEN SECONDS LEFFETON CALLING
DOESN'T GET A WHOLE SCORE.
IT'S DAVID KAMPF WHO'S RIGHT HE
WHAT A PLAY BY MARNER TO LEAVE
THAT CAMPBELL.
THE KRAKEN
WE HAVE A GREAT CREW.
YOU LOOK IT OVER THE T OUT.
FLEURY. FROM GEEKIE BEHIND THE
NET FOR DONSKOI TO CENTER.
NOW
JAKE ONE TIMER FROM OUT
TOP.